What is my opinion on open
relationships,
polyamory,
other forms of non monogamy?
Well,
I think that as a medium to longterm
strategy,
they're completely untenable because
human beings,
as far as I'm concerned,
are fundamentally pair bonding and you
know,
if you're just talking about casual sex,
first of all,
I think casual sex is a contradiction in
terms.
I don't think there's anything about sex
that's casual and I think that people
are deceiving themselves badly whenever
they think so they might like to live in
a,
you know,
19 seventies playboy,
adolescent fantasy.
But I don't,
I've never seen that work under any
circumstances whatsoever.
And I think people get hurt badly.
It's also a bad medium to longterm
strategy because,
you know,
pair bonding is a,
is the most stable arrangement we know
of at least so far.
Well,
I won't even put it that way.
It's the only stable a mode of being
that we know for the long run and that's
especially the case when you bring
children into the equation.
So,
um,
I think it's delusional fundamentally.
And I think that people who are,
who believe that such things work.
I mean,
sometimes they're open people in their
creative and their exploratory and all
of that and fair enough,
but often they're just unconscientious
and they don't want to take any
responsibility and they want to live in
this wish fulfillment fantasy where
everybody can have all the sex they want
all the time and it's always wonderful
and no one gets hurt and it's like,
sorry,
that just doesn't work in the real
world.